Becky is your modern Western woman what
Becky fails to understand is that she
has no prize she's Pastor Prime she
spent her early 20s partying drinking
smoking and doing too many drugs she
slept with so many men she's forgotten
half of them and when somebody asks what
her Notch count is she only remembers
the men that she was in longer term
relationships with but forgot the names
of most of the people she had one night
stands with friends with benefits with
had threesomes gave BJs to or had
lesbian encounters with Becky accepts
that she is incredibly interested in a
man's future to provide for her burning
desire for a family and children but is
unable to see that men of value aren't
particularly concerned with her future
but very concerned about her past and
baggage she doesn't see but nevertheless
brings to the table you see one of
Becky's biggest conundrums was that she
was sold the feminist lie of the strong
independent woman but she also painfully
feels the ticking of her biological
clock and Counting every egg that isn't
being fertilized monthly while watching
her friends and family have babies